iPhone 15 Ultra yes that is what's
rumored to be coming next year alongside
the rest of the iPhone 15 lineup and yes
that name is from the Apple watch Ultra
which is definitely the best Apple watch
ever made and there's going to be some
exclusive features on that model that
we're going to be talking about in terms
of the new leaks and rumors and I'm
gonna answer the question based off my
experience with the iPhone 14 pro Max
for the last couple of weeks should you
buy this one this year or should you
just hold off and wait for the 15 Ultra
or one of the other 15s next year let's
talk about it now getting into the
actual leaks for the iPhone 15 lineup
way back in January the analyst Jeff poo
said that the iPhone 15 Pro was expected
to feature the Periscope lens with up to
10 times optical zoom which is what the
current s22 Ultra from Samsung has and
let me tell you it greatly improves the
far Zoom Prof performance of the cameras
that would be awesome however going down
to July makes your quo actually said
that the Periscope lens would be
exclusive to the iPhone 15 Pro Max in
2023 and that itself could be renamed
the iPhone 15 Ultra which some other
reports I've talked about which I'm
going to get into however he does say
that he's expecting it to have a 6X
optical zoom which would be exactly two
times more zoom than the current 3x that
we have on the 13 Pro and 14 pro models
that would be a great increase in
quality and not only that but also
getting sensor shift stabilization which
actually matters a lot for long Zoom
cameras not only that but back in may
minchiko also said that the iPhone 15
lineup the entire thing would be getting
a USBC in 2023 now that is a huge deal
because Apple's been on Lightning for
the last decade and that's exactly what
they said when they first introduced
lightning so it's exciting that we're
finally going to switch over to USBC
next year now going even further in July
Ming shiko also said that the latest
iPhone chips the newest ones would
remain exclusive to the Pro Models for
the iPhone 15 and Beyond just like we
got with the 14 lineup or the pro and
pro Max have the new a16 chip while the
regular models are still stuck with the
a15 he basically says that this trend is
going to remain basically Beyond forever
and then interestingly in September Ming
Shakur also said that apple is going to
further separate the devices in the
iPhone 15 lineup with different features
so they're going to keep adding more to
the Pro Models while keeping the regular
models kind of further behind so it
looks like apple really really wants
people to spend more money on those Pro
Models now back in may we had a report
from the analyst Ross young who's
basically the best Apple display leaker
out there he said that apple is expected
to replace the notch on the regular 14
models with the new pill and hole on all
of the iPhone 15 models now of course we
didn't get the pill and hole we got the
full pill with the dynamic Island and he
says as you can see in this graphic
right here from his tweet that every
single iPhone 15 is gonna have the pill
plus hole which of course we do have
that Hardware wise right now on the pro
and next year there's going to be no
more notch on any iPhone so that's why
we recommended people to buy the pro
model so you don't feel like you have an
outdated notched iPhone with the regular
iPhone 14s and now here is where the
ultra rumors come in on September 25th
Mark German the most reliable Apple acre
said that the iPhone 15 Ultra could
replace the pro Max model next year now
he was the first one to hint at this but
we did have another leaker leaks Apple
Pro who was the first to make this claim
but of course Mark German solidified it
by saying that the ultra is coming just
like the Apple watch Ultra being the
highest and most expensive model the
ultra is gonna be the new Pro Max which
means that apple is likely gonna pack it
just jam-pack it with a bunch of extra
features and they're likely gonna hike
up the price to make it worth it to make
you feel like you want to pay more for
the ultra name you know and now here is
a very interesting report from inkja quo
saying that the iPhone 14 pro Max's
popularity could lead to more
differentiation between the 15 Pro and
the 15 Pro Max which is where it makes
sense to have that new Ultra name
because the pro Max is so popular this
14 pro Max model which I absolutely love
it has the better battery life even
though the always on display kind of
kicks down the battery life it's still
very good compared to previous years but
Ming shuko was saying that the pro Max
accounts for about 60 percent of the
total order increase of Pro Models which
is absolutely massive increasing Apple's
average sales price and that is huge for
apple and it makes sense for why they
would want to make a new Ultra model now
Ross young actually gave some reports to
his super followers showing that the 14
pro Max now has a big Advantage with
nearly one third of the volume of all
the iPhone 14 shipments which is huge
and you can see that right here in this
super tweet which by the way you know I
signed up for super following Ross young
five bucks a month definitely worth it
to see a chart like this and thankfully
he let me show off a couple of these
super tweets to you guys but look at
that Pro Max model right here bigger
chunk than all the other ones I honestly
don't think that this has happened
before that's huge for the pro Box model
and it makes sense why Apple would want
to do the ultra now moving forward this
next leak is going to be huge for people
deciding if they want to wait for the
iPhone 15 lineup or not specifically for
the pro and the ultra models tsmc has
their new second generation three
nanometer process that they're going to
be working on next year and that's going
to be for the M3 chip and the a17 going
into those 15 Pro and Ultra models that
is going to be a brand new process brand
new node and there's going to be some
huge efficiency improvements with that
in terms of battery life so I'm
expecting a really nice boost to battery
life for those Pro and Ultra models next
year I think that is going to be a huge
selling point for those now this past
Sunday Mark German released another one
of his power on newsletters and within
that he said that there's going to be no
touch ID for the iPhone 15 lineup next
year yes that means no under the screen
touch ID now I know that's been rumored
for a long time but I honestly think
that with face ID being so good I don't
think Touch ID is coming ever I think
Apple's just gonna scrap the idea and
even for the new iPhone se4 I think
they're just gonna give it a notch with
face ID just like the iPhone 10r I don't
think Touch ID is coming back ever prove
me wrong maybe you disagree with me let
me know in the comments below and then
now just the other day we got a report
saying that the new European law says
that iPhones must use USB type-c by 2024
which is making USBC more likely next
year Apple's probably going to want to
switch over their iPhones and then all
of their accessories to USBC to make it
all work in that lineup so it looks like
that law has finally passed but here is
where it gets even more interesting Joe
resignal from Mac Rumors is predicting
it now that was September 16th almost a
month ago that Apple will Market the
iPhone 15 Pro as having a thunderbolt
Port while the standard models get a
standard USBC more differentiation now
what if only the iPhone 15 Ultra model
gets the Thunderbolt Port because it's
Ultra it's more expensive it gets the
best of the best features that would
actually make sense for Apple to do to
give it a thunderbolt Port that is
insane and I think he might actually be
right now on top of that
here's where it gets even crazier
imagine boo he's had some very reliable
leaks in the past and according to one
of his sources the new iPhone 15 Ultra
is gonna have two front cameras not one
but two which is insane it's going to
have USBC and it's going to start from
256 gigs of storage which totally makes
sense they could even give it 8K video
recording just for the ultra model with
that 256 gigs and then the iPhone 15 Pro
is instead going to start with 128 it's
still gonna have USBC but only one front
camera that is kind of crazy and I
wonder what Apple's gonna do with the
second camera maybe some kind of ultra
wide or who knows so in his you he
believes it's going to be the iPhone 15
the iPhone 15 plus the pro and the ultra
with the ultra replacing the pro Max
just like Ming Chico was saying and then
finally here's a really really weird
thing apparently there's an iPhone with
no physical button and the project code
name is bongo so so no buttons on this
iPhone I'm not sure what this is gonna
be what it could be maybe the iPhone
fold or maybe the iPhone 16 or 17 I'm
not sure but this was an interesting
leak because shrimp Apple Pro is
actually very reliable he was the first
one to leak the new pill plus hole punch
combo on the front display which ended
up being true so with that said let me
give you guys some advice should you
upgrade to the 14 pro Max or should you
wait for the ultra well first of all I
think that if you really really care
about USBC then you should probably wait
but I've realized that I don't really
use the lightning port at all sometimes
I'll plug into the lightning to charge
but I'm almost always using Max save so
lightning really isn't a big deal and I
don't really take a bunch of videos and
photos and have to transfer them all the
time I don't really do entire iPhone
backups which would take forever using
the lightning cable I use basically air
drop and then I get a new phone and I
back it up through iCloud basically
every single year so it's not a big deal
to me and honestly the new camera is
really really good it's now topped the
s22 ultra and a lot of the other phones
the new 48 megapixel Pro raw is really
really good especially now that you can
actually use a shortcut to Auto convert
from prora to heic honestly this has
been a great phone it's the first one
with the new Dynamic Island and it's
basically really good so if you have
let's say an iPhone 10 iPhone 10s maybe
even an iPhone 12 model it's probably
worth it to upgrade but if you do have
an iPhone 12 13 and you're very happy
with it you don't have very many issues
then I would probably recommend that you
should wait till next year to get the
iPhone 15 Pro or Ultra model so with
that said hopefully you would enjoyed
this video and if you did click the
circle about to subscribe definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there including your iPhone 14 buyer's
guide which helps you choose one of
those models definitely check out that
guide thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]